je c je dans le
chemin pas facile de se mettre dans la
peau d'un aveugle quand on voit sans
problème l'association média handicap
basée à Montini le Bretonneux
sensibilise les valides aux
problématiques des handicapés depuis 9
ans maintenant objectif final permettre
aux handicapés d'accéder au métier des
médias et de la communication
l'association reçoit régulièrement le
soutien de personnalité cette année
c'est Philippe Candeloro qui a fait le
déplacement il y a beaucoup de de boulot
en France pour pour changer un petit peu
la vie des handicapés bon on essaie de
faire des choses sur les trottoirs les
choses comme ça je le vois même quand je
veux faire du rollur par exemple c'est
pas évident de de trouver des belles
routes en me disant mais comment ils
font les fauteuils roulants ils peuvent
pas circuler des fois il y a ça il y a
pas de trottoir ou alors c'est des pavés
c'est pas adapté bilan de ces 9U
dernières années de belles rencontres
mais aussi des avancées dans la prise en
compte du handicap on a interviewé
George
Clounet d'Amon au festival de canal on
est soutenu par le président Gill Jacob
du festival decal mais il y a pas que
l'aspect people il aussi l'accès
sensibilisation c'està dire on m'a on
m'a contacté pour que je mette en
situation de handicap per tes ingénieurs
qui vont travailler dans le domaine de
l'accessibilité de la voirie donc il y a
aussi des actions de fond qu'ils ont mis
en place jouer sur scène avec éedard ber
ou encore pagayet à contrecourant en
kayak avec un champion olympique malgré
son handicap Sébastien
se fixe en permanence des défis sa
manière à lui d'assumer sa différence et
d'en faire une
force